Dennis Wagner if you had to use only one
thing think small budget small budget to
generate massive media attention what
would it be and why this is this is the
million-dollar question here yeah but
here's the thing it it's a
million-dollar question because there is
no one thing like I cannot stress that
enough so Dennis unless you are best
friends with Oprah Winfrey there is not
this one thing that is going to you know
just caught a catapult you into math
success it's a combination of all of
these things working together but you
mean you have to have good stories so um
you know what is the one thing that I
can't live without sure I still use
press releases and that tends to you
know get me a lot of exposure for things
that I do here at Aweber if anybody
tells you the press release is dead
they're lying because it is still very
much alive and it's still you know very
profitable very successful so there's
things like that but the end of the day
it comes back to what is the story that
you're telling and so if the story is
there it trust me you're not going to
have any problems getting the mess of
the mass coverage and things like that
so it's always going to come back to the
story that you're telling an
entrepreneur so busy running their
company right like we're not slackers
we're working 80 hours a week already
just just running our business and now
we're telling people hey you gotta this
is important you got to do this too well
like added to the list of the other 100
things I need to do what what's the
starting point like we're d where would
you say someone like Dennis starts uh
but what's the first thing they should
do just start building a little bit
momentum around this just kind of
surveying the land to see you know in
terms of what I want to be known for and
others who are whether similar to me or
what I aspire to be for my business what
kind of media coverage are they getting
but then add on to that ok what do I
bring to the table that's fresh that's
new that's different and then you know
plan your attack and go from there but
it's always going to come back to the
story media coverage is not about hey
this is what I do here's what I'm
selling it's about here's the story
here's the value that it brings to your
audience and then once that story is
published the bang for the buck that you
get out of it that you're
name is in there they will start to
familiarize yourself familiarize
themselves with who you are and what
your business is but you got to have a
story they have something that's of
interest one of the things that helped
me when I was first getting started was
I made my own media list you know I
didn't have money to go hire somebody to
work for me or an agency I just wanted
to do it myself and I just made a list
of all of the reporters who were
covering my industry and then also my
local area so I'm from Toronto so any
Toronto publication I would I would
cover if I was turned over now I'd
probably expand it to also include the
online media youtubers Twitter people
and every week I would reach out to them
with a new story idea and it wasn't it
wasn't just like a promotional like hey
I've launched a new product it was a
story that I could imagine them
publishing on their website in their
magazine in the newspaper um always had
a catchy headline always have a catchy
second headline yeah I'm so glad you
said that that was one thing I wanted to
make sure i mention like when you're
thinking about media coverage think in
terms of headline that's right so you
know what are the headlines that you
typically see and whatever your story
idea is could you picture that as a
headline is that something that you
yourself would be interested in reading
if you opened up the newspaper or a
magazine so that's a really good point
think in terms of headlines yeah and so
like if you're pitching somebody on a
YouTube channel think about what would
the name of the video be called yeah
right if you're pitching somebody for an
article in newspaper but would the name
of that article be called yeah if you
can wow them and get their attention
then they're more likely to read write
the goal of the headline is to get them
to read the sub headline that gets in
the read the next paragraph to get them
to continue reading the story so i would
i would do that every every week i would
send that out to my list of a couple
hundred people that I made a list of and
every time I got picked up by somebody
whether it was a radio show whether it
was a newspaper sometimes it would even
just copy and paste and just print it
exactly as is because they love the
story and didn't even tell me about it
some of them so really important to
write like a story that you can imagine
appearing on their channel or in their
magazine or newspaper more than just a
pitch
what you do and some new product promo